EVERYONE HAS A FAIR VOICE
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY LIVE
IN A BIG CITY OR OUT IN THE
COUNTRY.
IN JOINING ME NOW FOR REACTION,
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK STILL
WINNING, "WASHINGTON TIMES"
OPINION EDITOR AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, CHARLIE HURT.
ALONG WITH RELATABLE PODCAST
HOST, ALLIE AND
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER" SR.
CAMPAIGN REPORTER KERRY PICKET.
CHARLIE, I WILL GO TO YOU FIRST.
WHAT I FIND COMICAL ABOUT THAT
AOC LITTLE HOME-VIDEO SHE DID
THERE IS SHE IS A MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES WHICH
IS THE BRANCH OF THE CONGRESS
ALLOCATED BY POPULATION.
SHE SEEMS TO HAVE MISSED THAT
WHOLE ENTIRE THING LIKE THE
WHOLE FEDERALISM, ELECTORAL
COLLEGE, REGIONAL REPRESENTATION
THING, RIGHT OVER HER HEAD.
RIGHT OVER HER HEAD COMPLETELY.
>> YEAH, AND OF COURSE THE
REASON THAT SUCH A PROBLEM FOR
US IS THE FACT THAT THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES IS OF COURSE THE
CLOSEST REPRESENTATIVES AND
REPRESENTATION TO THE PEOPLE.
SO FOR HER TO BE IGNORANT ON
THIS IS PRETTY DISTURBING BUT I
SAY TO HER, WELCOME TO THE
DISCUSSION 200 YEARS LATE AND OF
COURSE, IF SHE WENT BACK TO A
CIVICS CLASS LIKE IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL AND LEARNED ABOUT THIS,
SHE WOULD LEARN THAT THE WHOLE
POINT OF THIS DEBATE AND THE
WISDOM OF OUR FOUNDERS WAS TO
CREATE A SYSTEM THAT GAVE STATES
ENOUGH POWER TO BALANCE OUT, TO
BE A COUNTERWEIGHT TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AROUND AT OUR COUNTRY TODAY
AND YOU LOOK AT ALL THE PROBLEMS
WITH OUR GOVERNMENT, THE
PROBLEMS AREN'T IN STATE
GOVERNMENTS USUALLY.
THE PROBLEMS ARE WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND IF
ANYTHING, WHAT WE NEED MORE OF
IS MORE POWER GIVEN TO THOSE
GOVERNMENTS TO ACT AS A
COUNTERWEIGHT TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BUT ALL OF THAT GOES
OVER HER HEAD APPARENTLY.
>> Dan: SHE SEEMS TO HAVE
MISSED THE CIVICS CLASS WITH
HORIZONTAL AND VERTICAL CHECKS
ON POWER AND HOW WITHIN VOTING
FOR THE PRESIDENT WE DIDN'T BASE
IT ON THE POPULAR VOTE, WE
DIDN'T ELECT SOME REGIONAL
INTEREST.
THERE ARE FARMERS IN WISCONSIN
AND AS I SAID LAST NIGHT, SUCH
AS FARMERS IN FLORIDA WHO DON'T
WANT TO BE VOTED OUT ON A STRICT
POPULATION DIRECT DEMOCRACY
VOTES AND SHE SEEMS TO HAVE
MISSED THAT ENTIRELY AND YET SHE
WAS ONE OF THE MORE PROMINENT
MEMBERS OF U.S. CONGRESS NOW AND
ONE OF THE BIGGEST TWITTER
FOLLOWERS.
>> SHE SEEMED TO MISS A LOT OF
CLASSES APPARENTLY.
CIVICS, ECONOMICS, YOU COULD GO
ON.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT THERE WHATEVER
LOVE IS HOW TRANSPARENT THEY
ARE.
THEY TALKED ABOUT ABOLISHING THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE, GETTING RID
OF THE SENATE BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
FAIR, MAYBE EVEN MAKING THE CASE
OF GETTING RID OF THE
SUPREME COURT AND WE KNOW WHAT
THE THEME IS IN ALL OF THAT.
REPUBLICANS CONTROLLED THE
SENATE RIGHT NOW IN THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE GOT ELECTED
DONALD TRUMP AND THE
SUPREME COURT HAS CONSERVATIVE
JUSTICES ON IT SO WE KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THEIR MOTIVE IS.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE IT'S RACIST.
THAT'S ACTUALLY THE NARRATIVE
THAT SHE WAS PUSHING ON HER
INSTAGRAM STORY WHERE SHE HAD
MILLIONS OF FOLLOWERS AS WELL
BUT IT IS ACTUALLY A RACIST SCAM
BUT WE KNOW WHAT'S REALLY BEHIND
NOW.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY WANT CONTROL
PAID SHE IS PERFECTLY FINE WITH
PEOPLE IN L.A. AND SAN FRANCISCO
AND NEW YORK CITY RULING OVER
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THE SAME IDEOLOGY THAT
SHE DOES AND OF COURSE, AOC
KNOWS THAT.
>> Dan: WHAT I FIND MILDLY
AMUSING ABOUT THIS, ALMOST IN
KIND OF A TRAGIC WAY, THIS IS
REALLY NOT GOOD FOR A DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THAT IS HAVING A TOUGH
TIME RIGHT NOW ATTRACTING
WORKING-CLASS AMERICANS.
THEY ARE REALLY BECOMING A PARTY
OF THE ELITES DEMOCRATS.
I MEAN, YOU SEE YOU IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
IT'S A TOTALLY BIFURCATED CITY
RIGHT NOW AND YET SHE GOES ON IN
THE VIDEO POINTING OUT WHAT MAY
BE --
IT COULD BE ANY PUSH OF AMERICA
THAT'S NOT DENSELY POPULATED
WITH LIKE THE BRONX AND QUEENS
AND SHE JUST SITS THERE AND
TAKES A SHOT AT IT AS IF WE ARE
NOT IMPORTANT ENOUGH OR WE
AREN'T BIG-TIME CITYDWELLERS
LIKE HER.
WHAT KIND OF SILLY POLITICAL
STRATEGY IS THIS?
>> OBSOLETE.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
YOU HAVE JOE BIDEN AS WELL AS A
NUMBER OF OTHER PRIMARY
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE TRYING TO PICK
UP A NUMBER OF VOTERS ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY AND HERE YOU HAS AOC
WHO IS IN HER CAR SAYING THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE, IT IS JUST
NOT THAT FAIR.
I MEAN, COME ON.
WE HEAR ON THESE COASTAL STATES
THAT WE SHOULD BE GETTING BETTER
REPRESENTATION.
KEEP IN MIND, THIS IS SORT OF
THE CRY OF AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
LOST THE LAST ELECTION AND YOU
KNOW, THIS ISN'T REALLY UNUSUAL.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON BELIEVE
IT OR NOT SINCE 18 OH FOUR.
NEARLY EVERY SINGLE CONGRESS HAS
TRIED TO REFORM THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE SINCE 1804.
SO THIS IS HOW A LOSER CRIES
ESSENTIALLY.
>> Dan: IF SOMEONE LIKE BIDEN
WHO IS AT LEAST PRETENDING TO BE
A MODERATE WINS THE NOMINATION
AFTER THAT NOMINATION PROCESS IS
OVERCOME YOU KNOW HE'S GOING TO
TRACK BACK TO THE MIDDLE BECAUSE
THERE'S JUST NO VOTES TO WIN
NATIONALLY FOR A 90% TAX RATE
AND HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
WHAT DOES BIDEN DO WITH AOC AND
THE SQUAD?
I MEAN, HOW DOES HE HANDLE THAT?
DOES HE DISTANCE HIMSELF?
AND IF HE DOES, HOW DOES HE THEN
GET THAT LEFTIST SPACE THAT'S
ALL EXCITED ABOUT THEM TO SHOW
UP AT THE POLLS?
>> I THINK YOU PUT YOUR FINGER
ON SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT STRATEGY TODAY
AND THAT IS THAT COMING, IT'S
OBVIOUS THAT DEMOCRATS LIKE AOC
ARE DOING A LOT TO DAMAGE THE
PARTY IN THE EYES OF SORT OF A
GENERAL ELECTION ELECTORATE BUT
MY GOODNESS, I THINK THEY ARE
DESTROYING THEIR OWN DEMOCRATIC
BASE BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
RANKINGS WHILE REGULAR DEMOCRAT
VOTERS OUT THERE AND THESE ARE
THE PEOPLE THAT YOU SEE
REGISTERED IN THE POLLS FAVORING
JOE BIDEN WHO DON'T SUPPORT
DONALD TRUMP AND THEY CAN GIVE
YOU LEGITIMATE REASONS FOR NOT
LIKING HIM.
HENCE, THEY HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH RUSSIA OR RACISM.
THEY HAVE TO DO WITH OTHER
POLICY POSITIONS AND THEY ARE
COMPLETELY NOT REPRESENTED BY
ANY OF THESE LOONS AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHO ARE RACING
TOWARD THE LEFT WHO GIVE FREE OF
COWS AND TO ILLEGAL ALIENS AND
BILL de BLASIO WANTS TO GIVE
NEW YORK CITY HOUSING TO ILLEGAL
ALIENS.
THERE IS A LOT OF RANKING
DEMOCRATS WHO LOOK AT THAT AND
SAY THIS IS NOT FOR ME AND I
THINK DONALD TRUMP PICKS UP A
LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE BECOME
GENERAL ELECTION BUT BEFORE THAT
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY, I
THINK IT HURTS THE PARTY.
>> Dan: WHAT I FOUND PUZZLING
ABOUT THIS IS USUALLY THE
DEMOCRATS ARE A LITTLE BIT
SMARTER AT HIDING WHO THEY
REALLY ARE HERE.
THEY TRIED THIS BEFORE IN
ELECTIONS.
BUT WE TRY TO MONDALE, DUKAKIS,
THIS HAS BEEN TRIED BEFORE AND
THEY PROMPTLY GOT ANNIHILATED IN
THESE NATIONAL ELECTIONS.
IT'S NOT LIKE THERE IS NOT A
BODY OF EVIDENCE OUT THERE
SAYING HEY, LISTEN, IT'S KIND OF
A CENTER IS COUNTRY FAIR THIS
STUFF MIGHT BE A BAD IDEA AND
YET THEY ARE WALKING RIGHT OFF
THE CLIFF AGAIN.
>> NO, THEY'RE PLAYING TO A VERY
SECTOR MINORITY OF AMERICANS WHO
WANT A SUBSECTION OF MILLENNIALS
WHO THINK THAT ALL THIS STUFF IS
ELITIST AND THE GREATEST.
AND I THINK THEY'RE APPEALING TO
THEM.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THEM
MILLENNIALS DON'T NECESSARILY
TURN OUT AS MUCH AS THEY WANT
THEM TO BUT THERE ARE ACTUALLY A
FEW DEMOCRATS IN THE DEMOCRATIC
DEBATE IS EXACTLY WHAT YOU DID
THAT HEY, LOOK, WE ARE NOT GOING
TO WIN ON THIS PLATFORM.
DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO WIN AND
I THINK THEY ARE RIGHT BUT SADLY
FOR THEM, THEY ARE NOT LISTENING
TO THOSE VOICES.
DO A QUICK EXIT QUESTION BE OR
DO YOU THINK NANCY PELOSI AS
THIS ELECTION GETS CLOSER AND
THE PENALTY START TO BECOME VERY
REAL FOR MISSTEPS, BRINGS AOC IN
THE SQUAD AN END SAYS LISTEN,
YOU NEED TO CHANCES OUT A LITTLE
BIT, WE HAVE AN AUCTION TO
ENCOURAGE AMONG >> SHE TRIED
THAT ALREADY AND YOU KNOW,
FRANKLY, I THINK THAT NO MATTER
WHAT PELOSI SAYS TO THEM, AOC
AND THE SQUAD ARE GOING TO DO
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO AND SHE'S
ALREADY TOLD HER OWN CAUCUS,
GUYS, NO IMPEACHMENT, NOT RIGHT
NOW.
SO I HAVE A FEELING THAT'S GOING
TO BE A VERY TOUGH THING FOR HER
TO DO.